you do something great and then you come
back and you go we've got to raise the
bar again in a major franchise like thor
there's bound to be tears some sweat and
quite a bit of overall pain it does
become like a sport and you're sweating
and you there's injuries and so on
number one natalie portman did many of
her own stunts in thor love and thunder
which meant she had to be strong she
shares a bit about her training regimen
i trained for a long time before
enduring and i was doing the whole
protein shake thing it really helped
prepare me for the level of action that
we ended up doing even her costume was
heavy she needed a great deal of upper
body strength just to wear it throughout
the scene the costume designer created a
more comfortable lightweight version for
her to wear during breaks not only was
it lighter but the cape was also
shortened because it seems wearing capes
caused a lot of problems for the actors
as they would often trip over them and
get hit in the face during important
moments number two taika waititi had his
hands full as the director and the
character korg he basically had to be in
two places at once this is taika
performing chord but sometimes he's in
the suit the like motion capture suit
whilst directing sometimes he wasn't
actually there and the actors had to
pretend he was but most of the time he
was in full director mode while playing
korg at the same time the head you know
that's all there and there was attached
to a stick and that stick was attached
to his back essentially his head was
underneath cords the costume itself was
heavy and awkward so walking around in
it for long periods of time definitely
proved to be challenging this thing here
was attached on a harness remember that
and i also had the camera thing to
record my face talk about elaborate
number three speaking of elaborate
costumes
christian bale went through his own
trials and tribulations behind the face
of gore the godbutcher when he was first
cast he assumed gore was going to be
created with cgi but then he saw the
call sheet and noticed he had to come in
4 hours earlier than everyone else his
team of makeup artists got the process
down to three and a half hours but that
wasn't his only gore-related issue then
it wasn't until a couple of weeks later
i went wait what is this you know
because i'm swallowing an awful lot of
it yeah black bile he often had a lot of
it in his mouth while filming not only
that but christian found himself pretty
incapacitated because of gore's long
nails he tells deadline it affected my
brain i was like i can't eat i've got
long nails i was trying to type i
couldn't do anything number four chris
hemsworth is no stranger to pushing his
limits but when training for both his
fourth thor movie and a biopic for hulk
hogan he pushed himself a little too
hard though it's unclear exactly how it
happened he had to go see a specialist
for his back he opened up about the
struggles he faced i found that after
lifting weights for so long and not
getting in touch with my fast twitch
fibers the snappiness that my body had
has gone
number five you'd be surprised how much
effort went into making these screaming
goats they didn't bring any real goats
on set for those guys though because
they modeled them to be the size of
clydesdale horses it wouldn't have been
useful anyway all real hair all planted
in like each hair is actually planted in
by hand they had an entire team of
makeup artists on deck for these goat
scenes they'd run in with like a
glycerin spray and
just so the tongue was like extra wet
for that kind of reference the only real
goat they had on set was devin who
played a space goat let me tell you
devin is insufferable apparently though
very cute he wasn't the easiest to work
with because he loved eating all the
props i keep trying to explain to chris
that devin's not out to get him number
six
at first glance you might think being a
stunt double is a pretty dangerous line
of work at first glance you'd be
absolutely right bobby holland hinton
has doubled for thor james bond and
captain america and although he is an
absolute professional he still receives
a fair amount of serious injuries he
shares his most poignant onset injury
during thor i snap my groin up the bone
on thor ragnarok just doing a jumping
flip kick to try and kick the hulk in
the gladiator scene the timing of my
kick and the wire pull and me really
trying to go for it i hyperextended and
snapped a bit of my abductor longus and
rectus abdominis off the bone which took
a little while to heal
number 7 the actors of this film
described their sequences as high level
child's play for the first three days of
thor love and thunder christian bale had
to act with chris hemsworth natalie
portman and tessa thompson all gagged
and silent christian had a tiny
monologue that ended up being expanded
due to taika waititi's direction to a
massive monologue you were shouting
things at me and i was coming up with
stuff and
acting i felt like a demented nun or
something he had a really hard time with
it because he thought he was doing the
worst job ever especially because no one
could respond to him it was definitely
one of his least favorite moments also
given the fact that it was his first
introduction to the cast none of that
ended up in the film so i think that
must have been the answer
it was the worst
number eight definitely more awkward
than you'd think in thor ragnarok in
every scene that mark ruffalo who plays
the hulk performed he was isolated in a
completely different part of the set
that's how he performed all his hulk
scenes throughout the franchise except
for thor love and thunder we can thank
incredible technological advancement for
that i'm basically on one set swinging
this big hammer around so that means
when chris did his fight scene with him
he was also shooting by himself it can
make for several awkward takes we hoped
to see one day i think i probably did
more damage to myself just kind of
swinging the big thing around
number nine that's what it felt like for
tessa thompson anyway one thing we tend
to overlook about these superheroes is
their ability to wear awkward capes
while saving the world tessa found
herself tripping over her cape and
getting smacked in the face with it more
often than she liked she talks about her
strife with entertainment tonight you
just trip on them and then the wind
machine gets going and it smacks you in
the face so it felt like a quick boot
camp in superhero-ness and the sometimes
adventurous positions you have to get
yourself into to be able to you know pee
in between takes
number ten painful but it looked great
on camera okay well this is obviously
not tom this is a um a stuntman so tom
hiddleston stunt double paul luckavara
is strapped into a harness and a few
guys in the background are holding onto
his wires when chris throws him he is
pulled by the wires into the other men
ouch obviously actors are very valuable
and we do not want to damage the actor
number 11. this isn't the first time
jamie alexander suffered an onset injury
unfortunately the steps of her trailer
were out to get her that day she slipped
fell and hurt her back pretty badly she
posted on twitter um lucky i'm not
paralyzed luckily when it came to
shooting thor the dark world they were
able to work around her injury and
continue shooting all while giving her
time to recover
number 12 who knew 3d cameras could pose
such a problem marvel is famous for
their post credit scenes but this one
proved to be far more trouble than it
was worth joss whedon who directed this
scene used it as a test to see whether
or not they could shoot the avengers
with 3d cameras the answer ended up
being a hard no producer jeremy lacham
explains it took so long to change a
lens that it was truly awful it was the
longest day to shoot that tiny tiny
scene stellan skarsgard who was a major
player in the film said he didn't even
want to be in it if it was shot on those
cameras would you have known all of
these injuries mishaps and awkward
moments were happening behind the set of
the thor films let us know what you
think in the comments